veamos si podemos calcular el área de la
superficie de esta caja de cereal hay un
par de formas para resolver esto una de
ellas es calcular el área de aquellas
superficies que podemos ver y después
calcular el área de aquellas superficies
que no podemos ver ver cómo se pueden
relacionar y después sumarlas todas
vamos a hacer esto el primer lado
tenemos que tiene una altura de 20
centímetros una anchura de 10
centímetros es un rectángulo y para
calcular su área simplemente tenemos que
multiplicar la base por la altura en
este caso 20 centímetros por 10
centímetros nos dará un área de 200
centímetros cuadrados 200 centímetros
cuadrados es el área de este primer lado
vamos a escribirlo aquí
200 bueno también conocemos que hay otro
lado que tiene exactamente la misma área
que el frente de la caja que es la parte
de atrás de la caja así que escribamos
otros 200 centímetros cuadrados que
corresponden a la parte de atrás de la
caja ahora calculemos el área de la
parte de arriba de la caja la tapa de la
caja tiene 3 centímetros de profundidad
esto de aquí es 3 centímetros y tiene
una anchura de 10 centímetros
lo vemos aquí abajo así que el área de
la parte de arriba de la caja va a ser
tres centímetros por 10 centímetros que
nos da 30 centímetros cuadrados 30
centímetros cuadrados de área
corresponden a la parte de arriba de la
caja y la base de la caja también va a
tener la misma área simplemente no
podemos verla por lo que agregamos otros
30 aquí tenemos dos lados más ya que
esta caja tiene 6 lados
en este lado que tiene 20 centímetros de
altura y 3 centímetros de base así que
tenemos 3 por 20 estos 20 son de este
lado que voy a dibujar un poquito mejor
este lado mide 20 centímetros y 20
centímetros por tres centímetros nos va
a dar 60 centímetros cuadrados y esto es
este lado de la caja nos falta el otro
lado que no podemos ver el otro lado
tiene exactamente la misma área pero no
la podemos ver así que aquí agregamos
los 60 centímetros cuadrados de este
lado y otros 60 por el lado
correspondiente que no podemos ver y
ahora sumamos todas estas cantidades
tenemos cero esto es 3 más 36 más 6
ponemos 8 aquí llevamos una una más dos
más dos es igual a 5 nos quedan 580
centímetros cuadrados y esto es el área
de la superficie de esta caja